hello everyone our onions which was born
in Russia although he's considered to be
a Danish chess master and he was a
well-known writer but also he was
considered to be one of the strongest
players in the world from in the period
of 1920s to 1930s he was considered to
be the third strongest player in the
world bested only by Alexandre de acero
capablanca he even defeated even a
couple of times even drew one match
against him even though when it
consisted only of two games but he never
managed to defeat capablanca and this
game was played in 1927 aron nimzowitsch
with the white pieces against system son
except it wasn't and this game was
actually composed by a very good friend
of nimzowitsch
mr. Hans Comeau because well the names
of each was known to be somewhat of an
eccentric and this one time a handsome
handsome Oh who was directing a
tournament held in bled in 1931 and well
the Queen herself was expected to arrive
at the tournament with her children and
her ninja which walked to the tournament
hall only wearing a bathrobe so he sat
there in the middle of the tournament
hall and he was almost naked and
handsome oak was outraged
he thought that well the Queen might
arrive and look at this names of each
guy here he's just you know sitting
naked in in the middle of the tournament
hall and so he grabbed names of each and
he kicked him out of the door and well
names which considered this to be very
funny and so so this game was probably
composed as as a way for Hans more to
get back at names of it as names which
did play a very famous game in 1923
called the immortal took Swan game and I
will show this game on my channel on
some other occasion so Hans Hans Mach
actually published this game as if our
names of which was playing it and he
called it the mortal overprotection game
so let's see this game not played
between arrow names of each and systems
own we have E for my name is H and E 6
the French defense and here are names
which plays H for and he says that well
to an untrained eye or even to a very
strong player this might seem like a
weird move but it's actually a brilliant
so black replies d5 and here her name's
though it says well black replies as if
this was a normal French defense but
it's not and he plays 'if I've and hear
names of it says that well although this
ePHI pawn is a weak pawn the move e5 is
actually a very strong move as you'll
see later in the game so black replies
c5 and here names which again says that
black is simply continuing to play as if
this was a normal French defense game so
he plays d4 and the names of says that
well this is a lot better than playing
d4 and I moved to because this will uh
well black is usually allowed to play c5
to attack your d4 pawn but now names
which plays d4 to attack blacks e5 pawn
so we have C captures and before and now
need to place a brilliant move here he
goes h5 and he says that well this move
will definitely decide the outcome of
the game we have Queen to b6 by system
son and now h6 a very deep pawn
sacrifice we have Knight captures on h6
and now names which plays Queen to h5
and to an untrained eye again this would
seem like a very weird move because well
this practically invites black to play
g6 which he does he gets rid of the
Queen on h5 and while he's preparing to
develop the bishop on g7 and start
attacking this week a five pawn but now
names oh it says that now you will see
that this a five point is not a week at
all and names which place Queen to h2
and now you see that this Queen is
protecting the e5 pawn extremely well
and this ePHI pawn is really cramping up
blacks position so we have a night stay
at five as the knight was attacked on h6
we have Bishop to d3 Knight to c6 now
attacking that a five pawn and now
nimzowitsch says although Knight f3 is a
pretty standard move in this game it's
it's a brilliant move because it now
adds over protection to the e5 pawn and
he goes Knight f3
we have h5 black is ready to develop
this Bishop and this h5 move also
prevents white from well infiltrating
with his dark square Bishop and here
names which sets a brilliant trap he
plays b3 and he says that well someone
who
understand chess although mr. Sisson is
one of the greatest scandinavian players
he will assume this diagonal with his
bishop and well beat white to it and he
plays Bishop to g7 but now names o
strikes with Bishop to f4 and our names
are says he was never really planning to
develop this Bishop to b2 as though now
he is protecting this a 5-pound three
times so we have Bishop to d7 and now
Knight B to d2
we have ripped the c8 and here names o
says that black played rook to see it
because well he simply doesn't have a
good move into position and now another
really moved by names of which we have
in - E - this is preparing rook to e1 to
add even more protection to the e5 pawn
as nimza says he who over protects wins
the game we have nice to be four and now
another brilliant move by names of which
he plays Knight to e1 we have a 9th
captures on d3 9th captures on d3 and
now rook captures and c2 and Enzo says
that capturing this pawn is a total
waste of time for black and well this
this c2 phone is completely irrelevant
for the rest of the game and that we
have look 81 adding even more protection
to this a 5 point we have a 5 and now
Kings to d1 would a temple on the rook
we have rook to c6 and now rook the e2
preparing to double up on the e-file to
add even more protection to the e5 pawn
we have King to e7 and we have rook H 2
e 1 now this e 5 phone is really
protected and now nimza says well black
black is probably is starting to copy
the names of each as now black starts
over protecting his east six pawn but
it's too late for such things so we have
a look - he ate and now Knight to f3
adding even more protection to the e5
pawn now every piece White has is
protecting the e5 pawn and this is I
want a one position says names of each I
will have Bishop to f8 and now him so it
says that black is ready to play Knight
to g7 and wealth
add even more protection to his East six
pawn and now Bishop to g5 is well
definitely the best move here
Putnam's which plays an even better move
he plays g4 black responds with h
captain g4 attacking the knight but now
Queen to h7 is coming and mr. systems
and captures the knight G captures on f3
and well names which ends the game with
the Bishop to g5 checkmate
and even if black didn't capture this
Knight if he played something like well
Knight to g7 the block Queen and also to
allow him to go f6 then simply Bishop to
g5 check f6 Bishop captures on g5 which
on f6 were checking this f7 and now
Knight to g5 with checkmate and well I'm
sure this was very funny
both the Mr Hunt Morgan and I'm sure
names of each found this very amusing
even though after for example after
Queen to h7 if black decided to play a
rook eat the c8 this is well this is
completely winning for black white it
doesn't really have any counter play
here but as this was a composition by
his good friend Hanscom off the game
ended in Bishop to g5 with checkmate so
yeah it's a well it's a game that never
really happened but it is a beautiful
game so nice one mr. Han's more and like
I said I will show the names of which is
a real the immortal Chuck's one game and
yeah I do hope you enjoyed this game and
a lot of people in chess calm you know I
mean I'm Ches Ches Gamescom they think
that this game actually happened and
then there are a lot of comments about
how this game seems pretty suspicious
and that it's you know kind of kind of a
weird game so I do want to assure you
that this game never really happened and
it's purely for amusement so yeah that's
it for this video I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and that's it thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon and of course I would like to thank
mr. Allan furnace for a contribution to
my channel I really appreciate it thank
you thank you lot sir
so yeah see you soon